[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: I'm excited to
open up our talk today
and to introduce you to
two incredible leaders.
Let's start with this.
How do real people succeed
in the real world of work?
Kind of a loaded question,
but how do they do it?
What is their secret sauce?
That's the question that
bestselling author Joanna Barsh
sets out to answer,
but not by talking
to well-established CEOs
or motivational gurus.
Instead, she dives
into the trenches
with some of today's
brightest and boldest up
and coming leaders.
With over 30 years at
McKinsey and Company
and three books to
her name, we really
have a lot to learn from Joanna.
She's here to distill the
stories of over 200 rising
leaders from 120 companies
around the globe,
all with the aim
to help Millennials
grow through the
challenges we face at work.
We're also joined
by Amy Yury, who
is a 15-year veteran
of Google and has
held multiple leadership
roles on the advertising
side of the business.
Amy currently oversees
developing video ad products
for Google Marketing
Solutions globally.
She is also a founding member
of the Women@Google Leadership
Board and hosted
Joanna back in 2012
at one of the first
Women@Google Leadership Summits.
Without further ado, I'm going
to bring Joanna and Amy up
to the stage.
Joanna is going to dig into
some of the key learnings
from her recent book
before being joined
by Amy for a fireside chat.
I just ask that you make sure
you're sitting next to someone,
as there is an activity
that will take place
during Joanna's talk,
and it's important
that you've got a buddy.
And without further ado, let's
give Joanna a warm welcome.
JOANNA BARSH: Well, thank you.
And I can see the
gentleman over there,
you sit next to that
nice lady, right one--
and I'm here.
Yeah.
If you're sitting
by yourself, just
squidgy over, which
is a technical term,
for sitting next to somebody.
And the two of you are like
back to back, front to back.
Now you should sit on
this-- sit together.
Come on.
This-- it won't
be painful, and it
won't take much time,
because I've only
been given 10 to 15 minutes.
So I'm going to talk like a New
Yorker, really, really quickly,
and see if I can get you
curious about yourself,
about the challenges that
you're facing at work,
and maybe we can have a
conversation about that very,
very shortly.
So let's start with the first
risk, which is you're here.
You took a risk.
Today was a big day
in New York, and we
are proving that terrorism
is nothing to New Yorkers.
So we've already
jumped off a cliff.
What does it feel like?
What about your work?
Think about the risks that
you could be taking at work
and you may be thinking
about or avoiding.
So what risk are
you taking today,
given that the subways
are now working again.
So that's no longer a risk,
that you couldn't get here.
Think about it during this talk.
I started out in 2015
after 30 something years,
as Taylor said, at
McKinsey, to actually talk
to younger people.
Why?
Because it's really
awful talking
to CEOs who have made it.
They have their stories,
men and women alike,
and they've been media trained.
And so it's very hard to
actually get to know them.
Younger people don't have
their stories finished yet.
It's very exciting.
You don't know how
it's going to turn out
after you've interviewed them.
So I thought it was
a fabulous idea.
I reached out to
100 or so companies.
There are about 15
start-ups in the group.
There are also individuals
who are actors, artists,
scientists, lawyers, doctors,
not your normal big company
employees.
Every single one
of these people was
considered by the
person recommending
them to be high
performing, high potential.
So that's the base.
And I also talked to
another 55 HR professionals
about them, which
was very enjoyable.
And we'll see what came
out of that in a moment.
And I basically said,
what defines you?
Let's talk about your
childhood and how you grew up
and what you think of now.
What's coming to you now.
It's kind of a deep
psychological interview
which worked pretty--
I found some interesting
things out about people.
And then I asked them about
what is a high point at work
or low point at work
in the last year.
And I just collected those
and got those stories,
which are amazing.
I also asked people, what do
you think about Millennials?
And I got an earful.
What do you think about women?
Interesting.
We could talk about that later,
why I asked that question, what
do you think about women.
And I meant it in a
truly collegial way.
And what do you
think about work.
So we have a whole battery
of what Millennials think.
And it is myth busting.
But first, the
weird thing happened
that this group of people,
which I had not thought about,
turns out to be the most
diverse group of people
ever that I think have
appeared in a book.
So they're from
all over the world.
They're people working in the
US from 80 different countries.
I'm sure in this room we have
a similar dispersion of where
people come from
and what experiences
you've had in life already,
and that's part of diversity.
They also-- I met
married people,
single people, single
people with children,
married people with
children, people working
every function you can imagine.
People who didn't go to college.
People who went to
premier colleges.
You name it, I met those people.
So that, to me, says we've
got an interesting pool
of experiences.
What can we learn from them?
Well, here's the
first thing we learn.
A lot of people
make their living
off of talking
about Millennials.
I do not.
First of all, I don't really
make a living anymore.
But secondly, when
I talk to people,
I generally talk
about leadership.
So you probably
recognize these words
that people talk about when
they talk about Millennials.
My favorite being
the trophy hunter.
But as one Millennial told me,
let's just think about lazy.
I'm sure in the baby
boomer generation,
there are plenty of
lazy people as well.
So before we cast
aspersions on Millennials,
let's look at every generation.
So I did.
And this is what I learned
as well about older people,
myself included.
And I like the slow, because
I am a little bit slower
these days, at 64.
But nonetheless, this
is complete bullshit.
So you already knew that.
I haven't taught you
anything new yet,
so I'm going to keep going.
This is what they told me.
To me, if you think about
your life in these terms,
it's pretty scary.
Right?
You're at a place, and
you've just made a mistake.
And you know that mistakes
are not an option here.
Or that you wake up
every day and say,
I don't even know
why I'm working here.
Because work has
no passion for me.
And everybody says I
should have passion.
What about pressure?
You all have deadlines.
Pressure is the kind of
thing that destroys health.
It boils over, and
then you lose sight
of what it is that's
really important to you.
What if you were working
with bullies and villains,
and I wrote tough characters.
But come on, for the record,
we know who they are.
They're assholes.
Why are you working for them?
What if everybody says you
have to have a sponsor,
and you know in
your heart, there
is no sponsor in the
people around you.
And you don't know
how to get one.
You're not even
sure you want one.
You just got a bad review.
Literally whacked
you over the head,
and then the person
giving you the review
says, well, what do
you think about that?
It's like, what?
What do I think about that?
Then you're given an assignment.
You're a superhero.
You feel really
good about yourself.
And it turns out, it's
Mission Impossible.
Nobody's ever succeeded
doing that before,
but you've got the job.
And my favorite of all
favorites, you wake up,
and everything sucks.
What is everything sucks?
That's a military
term, by the way.
It comes from the Army.
What this means is that
your job is going badly.
Your relationship just exploded.
You have been gaining
weight at a steady pace,
as you're badly eating, since
you're not sleeping enough.
And then finally,
even your mother
calls you up to yell at you.
Right?
So everything sucks
in that scenario.
And then the final chapter of
this book is work just isn't--
you have passion,
but not for this.
Work doesn't feel worth it.
What do you do?
Do you go, or do you stay?
Do you wait it out or not?
So those are all the challenges
that are in this book.
And every story in this
book is, if you would,
instant experience for you.
So you don't need to be
64 years old and thinking
about your whole life
deeply, as the other training
that I do for Google.
You can just read the story.
So I give you the story of Greg.
Let's meet Greg.
He's a sports writer.
He has a dream job writing
for a famous magazine.
He's what he likes
to call a bro.
So Greg's a bro.
A very bright one.
And lo and behold, six months
into his job, his father
is hospitalized with a failing
heart and probably will die.
So Greg quits his job.
Doesn't even think about it.
He moves into the hospital to
help his father run his finance
business.
The father needs a heart,
but he is not very high
up on the donor list,
and time is running out.
So what does Greg do?
Greg says, I'm going to
find out about donations
and see if I can
solve this issue.
And that's what he did.
He got into it.
And then he realizes the
entire industry of donations
is an old boys' club.
None of the CEOs of
any of these businesses
want anything to do with
Greg, who's a 26-year-old guy.
He says he looks like he's 12.
So he doesn't have
a lot of gravitas.
But he comes out
of this situation--
there is good news here, and
I'll get to it in a minute.
He comes out of this situation
able to change his job,
help his father, and start
a new business, which
we'll talk about.
But before I get to the
punchline of that story.
one of the tools that comes
out of this chapter, which
is bringing others
on board is something
that I learned from Greg.
And so I want to
test it out on you.
Are you OK being guinea pigs
for the next two minutes?
OK.
The guy in the back says
fine, so the rest of you
please come along.
Here's what we're going to do.
Pair up.
And if you're a trio, then one
of you can be the observer.
And you sort of Dr.
Freud-like, just
sit there like this during
the next two minutes.
One of you will be a speaker.
One of you will be a listener.
And if, again, as I said, you
don't want to do this exercise,
listen in to somebody
who's doing it.
You'll learn a lot.
Speakers, you know
who you are, you
are the one who's
willing to talk
to the guy or lady next to you
about something that seriously
is important to you.
It probably is
bothering you right now.
So you're going to get two
minutes of free coaching.
Listener, there is only
one thing you have to do,
which is listen.
OK?
That's it.
Everybody ready?
You got your pairs?
Go.
I should hear noise now.
[CHATTER]
Sh.
OK.
Who amongst the
listeners said something?
Spoke.
Said anything, like ah, uh,
eh, yeah, that happened to me,
or yeah.
How did it feel to listen
without saying anything.
Did anybody succeed
in the two minutes?
She did?
So what did it feel like?
Just shout it out.
AUDIENCE: It feels
like I wasn't relating
to her by not saying anything.
JOANNA BARSH: It's hard
not to say something.
That's interesting.
Did anybody who is among
the speakers, did you find--
what did you find,
speaking for two minutes?
Having the floor.
Did anybody have the floor
for the whole two minutes?
Yeah?
What did it feel like?
AUDIENCE: Weird.
JOANNA BARSH: Weird.
I love it.
Weird.
It felt weird.
What was weird about it?
AUDIENCE: There was no response.
JOANNA BARSH: Yeah.
Oh, it's like we-- it's very
hard to talk for two minutes.
But did anybody have a
different experience?
You got to talk for
two minutes, and--
AUDIENCE: I was like, I have
a lot to say about this.
JOANNA BARSH: Yes.
Yeah.
Isn't it wonderful that somebody
is listening for two friggin'
minutes?
You felt the same way?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
It was good to sort of
vent and just get it out
and to think about it.
JOANNA BARSH: And have
somebody hear you and see you.
So I have done this
experiment last week in Dubai,
and I found that
half the room thought
it was weird and really
hard to fill two minutes,
and the other half thought
it was like 10 seconds.
It just flew by.
So there's a right answer here.
But the act of listening is the
most powerful leadership skill
you can develop.
So if you have a
team, and you truly
can listen with your heart,
not from our normal stance
of listening, which is I
wonder if that person's
right or wrong.
I wonder if I'm
learning something
I didn't already know.
What I'm going to say
to that person is--
where you stop listening.
The minute the
voice in your head
starts, you are no
longer listening,
even if you think you are.
So learning to just listen from
their stance, not from yours,
is a huge skill.
So that's the tool.
What happened to Greg?
Well, you notice that Greg
is no longer a sportswriter.
He is now a founder
and CEO of a nonprofit
which is called Organize.
Of course, right?
Organs.
Donating.
Organize.
There you go.
And it turns out, as Greg's dad
was on the way to the hospital
with his wife to have an
end-of-life counseling session,
a 26-year-old in Massachusetts
died in a car accident
or a motorcycle accident.
And while he was HPV positive,
his heart was in good shape,
and therefore Greg's
father was the next person
on the list at this
hospital, got the heart,
and survived, which
is pretty amazing.
But that's actually
not the story.
The story is that Greg learned,
as he started up Organize,
to listen and stop
selling his ideas.
And he shifted from telling
people to asking people,
and that made all the
difference to the donors
that came on board.
What he learned is that if
you actually engage people
with the problem, I have
this really hard problem
I'm trying to solve.
Can you help me?
People's brains get
engaged so fast.
They can't stop thinking
about your problem.
And now they're on
board, and it turns out
the money is the easy part.
So that is what
Greg learned, and he
managed to bring a guy named Al
Roth on board who won a Nobel
Prize for designing markets.
He was teaching at
the time at Harvard.
He's now somewhere else.
I haven't tracked him down.
But this is a very cool story,
to bring someone like that
on board to a start-up.
So Greg learned that lesson.
So now you've got listening,
and you've got asking,
but what else could you do
if bringing people on board
is your challenge of the day?
Start with your intention.
Start as you go into a
meeting, or you go talk
to members of your team.
What is it you really
want to create?
If you have that squared
away, then everything
will fit into that framework.
Most of us don't
start with that.
Most of us just start
with I'm just here,
and let's see what happens.
Stand in the other
person's shoes,
which you know how to do.
The hard part is to
let go of judgment.
We always stand in their
shoes, and then we judge them,
because we're human beings.
Everybody does that.
But if you can learn
to stop judging
and get curious
about that person,
you will actually create a
connection that is very strong.
You don't have to love them.
You just have to try
to understand them.
Listen from their center,
not your own center.
And ask really good questions.
A good question is a
question that doesn't just
have a yes or no answer,
pretty often does not
start with the word
why, and opens up
possibilities for solutions.
So what are you
trying to create is
a great question to somebody who
you might be having a conflict
with.
Tell me more about what
you're trying to create.
Be present, not dominant.
What does that mean?
Well, we know what
dominant means.
It means I am the smartest
person in the room,
so I'm just going
to keep talking.
And being present means I'm
alert and focused and here
with you.
Which is better?
If you want to connect to
people, it's pretty clear.
Being present is going to get
you a lot more connections
than big dominant.
And the final to do is
to use silence as a tool.
Silence is really uncomfortable.
It is also weird.
And all of us fill it.
If you learn to not
fill it, the good thing
is, somebody in your
team will fill it,
and they might
tell you something
you didn't know or have a
really, really good idea.
So practice silence.
And if someone asks you a
question in a big meeting,
use silence.
It will cause everybody to
listen harder if you use it.
So those are my thoughts.
We-- I was told.
Did we do 10 minutes?
Come on up, Amy.
Because at this point, I am
becoming dominant and not
present.
So I give it to you.
AMY YURY: Please, everybody,
give Joanna a warm welcome.
JOANNA BARSH: Oh, actually,
I want to go one more.
Diogo, you'll help me.
One more.
So this is the big so what.
Amy went through training and
centered leadership with me.
I was really, really honored
to have people from Google
as part of our training when I
was at McKinsey and shaping it.
This is the big so what.
You're an iceberg.
We all see what you say and
what you do, what you don't say,
what you don't do.
That's what we see.
That's all we see, and
that's what we judge.
And you are so much
more than that.
Underneath that is everything
you're thinking and feeling
and you're never
going to disclose.
And underneath that
is you're really
thinking about what matters
to you, what you believe,
what your values are.
Sometimes you don't
even know, but that's
what's driving your behavior.
And underneath that
is your human needs.
Often people talk
about it as fear,
but actually, it's
what is your deepest,
deepest need as a human being.
And that is what drives
all of the behavior.
Everything that's down there.
So if you start to think
of yourself in that way,
without judgment, you're
going to learn a lot.
And as you read through
other people's stories,
you can put yourself in them
and accelerate your own growth.
That's what I had to say.
AMY YURY: Thank you.
Yeah, no.
It's an honor to have
you back at Google.
And yes, I do remember
many of these exercises
as part of the Centered
Leadership Program.
And specifically some of
the young childhood memory
exercises, where you asked
us to look back and talk
about experiences
that shaped us.
So it's an honor to have
you back, and thank you
for coming off of
a trip from Dubai.
Joanna has been traveling
around the world,
talking about this book, and
obviously, centered leadership.
And you mentioned
that your first book,
"How Remarkable Women
Lead," was focused
on what you would call the
"more experienced" work set.
So what drove you
to say, all right.
Maybe I should gain
new perspective.
What created that sense
of curiosity for you?
JOANNA BARSH: So
it actually started
with this young lady
who is in the room,
in the front row, who
doesn't work at Google.
Oh my god!
[LAUGHTER]
She said, I think
your book is boring.
And she was my--
she's my daughter.
She's allowed to say that.
And so it's actually--
it's really OK.
And I asked her what she meant.
And she said, they're so old,
these leaders, I can't be them.
I'm not even sure
I want to be them.
And so how do I get there
from here is a mystery to me.
And I began to think about,
well, what about people
under the age of 40?
What is happening to them,
and is it different today
than it was 40 years ago?
I mean, some of the people
I interviewed were 80.
And I was on the edge of my
seat to make sure they made it
through the interview.
They were amazing
people, but they
lived in a different
environment,
in a different situation.
And today, I'm impressed.
I'm in awe of Millennials.
So I thought it
would be really cool,
as I was retiring from
McKinsey, to hang out
with a bunch of people who
actually had a lot of hope
for life.
AMY YURY: And was it?
JOANNA BARSH: It was.
And was-- I'm still
interviewing people.
So if anybody wants to be
interviewed, just let me know.
In fact, somebody in this
room was interviewed,
but I'm not going to tell you
who it is, because everybody's
confidential.
AMY YURY: So what was
the epiphany for you,
in terms of what would
resonate in the way
that it changed the way
you wrote this book?
I've obviously read
both, and the style
of "How Remarkable Women
Lead" versus this story
is a little bit different.
Can you talk about
what changed that?
JOANNA BARSH: So one interviewee
said, I'm through with school.
I just don't need to
be taught anymore.
Adults learn by doing.
And the adults that
I'm trying to reach,
everybody in this
room, you don't
have that much experience.
You might have six years,
10 years of experience.
And it's your experience,
so it's really important,
but wouldn't it be
really cool to have
instant experience of all
these other people who
faced the challenge
that you're now facing,
but they did it
differently than you.
So at least they'll give you
something to think about.
So that's what I wanted to do.
I wanted to collect a
tapestry of stories.
Now, the internet is full
of people with stories,
and I started to look at
them, and they're fake.
It's like Susan had an issue.
And then it gives
you one paragraph,
and then in the second
paragraph, she solves the issue
and gets promoted.
Or she doesn't solve the
issue, and then the author
says, tsk, tsk.
Had Susan only
asked the question,
she would have whatever.
Gotten the brass ring.
So I wanted to write
stories that you go,
what's really going to happen?
And the answer is, I don't know.
because they haven't lived
their whole life yet.
Will that person become famous?
I don't know.
But to me, they became
very, very interesting.
The second thing I wanted
to do is make it real.
And you could argue with me that
it's not real enough for you,
and that may indeed
be the truth.
But I didn't want
to say, Amy, just
I want to leave
you with thinking
about why you're
so uncomfortable
about that question.
Instead say, Amy, why don't you
go meet that person over there
and have a discussion about
what gets them excited?
That's something
you could actually
do, as opposed to go home
and go, what did she say?
So that was my goal.
AMY YURY: You did something
at the end of every chapter
as well to try to give a
tool kit for folks to think
about how to solve
the challenge.
How did you think about
creating the different solutions
that you did, and
is there any order
in which you could go through in
solving these work challenges?
JOANNA BARSH: You know,
everybody's challenge
is different.
And I became quite humble.
I could only put-- the
original book had--
it was like 400 pages, and
it had 120 stories in it.
And now it's 75 stories.
And you may still
find it too long,
but nonetheless, I went
through all the stories,
bottoms up, kind of like a
Google data mining exercise,
although I was an English major.
I apologize.
And I found what these
people did, and then
through my own experience
of centered leadership
and me at McKinsey and being
a consultant and on and on,
I put them into a
structure, which is first--
one CEO once said to me, just
tell me what to do first,
second, third.
In that order.
So I tried to order the actions
at the end of each chapter
based on if you don't know
where you are, start at the top.
And if you've already
done that, go to the place
where it's now news for you.
AMY YURY: Great.
I know that managing people,
people always say, OK.
Well, where do I start?
How do I do this?
So I appreciate you giving
that specific advice.
I loved the titles
of the challenges.
And you went through
all of them upfront.
Some of them definitely
probably hit closer to home
for Googlers, including the what
do you do after a poor review,
because we just had our perf
review cycle, so everybody
just got their annual
feedback and might still
be digesting and thinking, OK.
Now what do I do next?
I also love some of
the titles, including
when you have to be a
superhero, because working
for a company like
Google, I know
people feel like the
bar keeps moving higher,
and the task keeps getting
bigger, and to your point,
I have to solve a problem that
nobody's ever solved before.
I personally love
when risk-taking
feels like jumping off a cliff.
And for some of us, we either
enjoy jumping off cliffs,
or are afraid of heights.
What is your favorite
challenge in the book?
JOANNA BARSH: When I woke up
this morning, for some reason,
I was thinking, because
of that jump off a cliff
thing, of cliff divers.
Which I woke up with
a semi heart attack.
I was like, I don't
want to do that.
So my favorite chapter is
actually when everything sucks.
Because it came from a
military story of a woman who
had been to Afghanistan.
And she taught me some things
that I had really never thought
about.
I don't know if anybody
has military experience
in the room, but it's completely
different than anything
in life.
So I put her in the
book for that reason.
And there were other people
where everything sucks,
for example, a
woman who started up
a really cool business with her
friends from her prior work,
and she was kicked out by those
"friends" and on her own one
June morning and had
to restart herself.
So there are all kinds of
situations where you find--
a man who worked in
an automotive company
who his marriage
started falling apart.
He was working on the
most exciting thing,
renewable energy in cars.
He was totally
committed to this.
And then they shut
his project down,
which I'm sure happens at
Google once in a while.
And he just imploded.
And somebody said
to him, one day,
you'll tell your grandchildren
about this project.
And he was thinking,
I don't have a job.
I'm not going to have
any grandchildren.
So he had to pull
himself together.
So that's why I
like that chapter.
But what it does is it helps
you prepare for something
that hopefully
you'll never be in,
but I'm sure you will,
because work ends up,
after a great week,
the next week it sucks.
And you didn't ask for it.
And the first thing
you do to prepare
is to be mentally,
physically, emotionally,
and spiritually resilient.
Which I hadn't
thought about, which
is why the military
forces people
to go through physical
training that's awful.
Because you develop
stamina and resistance
and alertness in the
midst of the unexpected.
AMY YURY: So
resilience, curiosity,
bravery, what are some of these
attributes that if you look
at the collection of
stories and the people
that you've seen, obviously
their stories are not complete.
But what are some
of the attributes
that you've seen are common
amongst those that have learned
how to overcome
challenges and even
reframe challenges
as opportunities?
JOANNA BARSH: Yeah.
So people-- do you remember that
first slide with stereotypes?
People think of Millennials
as waiting for someone
to hand them the answer.
And I didn't find that at all.
I found the strongest element
to be curiosity and bravery.
So a challenge is
something you really
don't want to face because you
know it's not going to be fun,
and it might
actually be painful.
And yet the people who
faced these challenges
did so because they were
driven by a desire to grow.
And some of them
were driven by fear.
So a fear that if they didn't
grow, they would fall behind.
And in this
generation, if there's
one theme that I
didn't know I would
find it is that you are
growing up with uncertainty.
And when I grew up in the '50s,
it was like fake certainty,
but it was certain.
You lived in a house, and
your dad came home at night.
And you never saw him, but
you knew he was working
and everything was cool.
And you played, and
that was your job.
Just to play everyday.
Whereas today, I think
people, from the internet,
from being global
citizens of the world,
from having parents
who've lost their jobs,
you grow up with uncertainty.
And that means that
you've got to be
growing wherever you work.
Because you're in charge of you.
You already know that.
Now it's up to older people
who manage you to realize
that that's what's driving you.
And once you're an
owner of your future,
then you basically measure
everything in terms of
am I growing.
And challenges are
the best way to grow.
So the people in this book,
they didn't all succeed,
but they all took
the challenge on.
AMY YURY: In looking at
the stories of people
and those that are
continuously growing, did you
find any differences,
in terms of the stories
from men or women?
JOANNA BARSH: [LAUGHS] I
counter-programmed the book
because there was no
theme that I found.
Maybe you could prove me wrong.
But men told me that women were
more aggressive, more driven,
more goal-driven, were
really kicking ass.
And women told me that
men were more courageous,
willing to take a
chance, and kicking ass.
So it was-- and there were all
kinds of people in the book.
So I put in men who were afraid,
men who made mistakes and had
to live through it, and I put
in women who were totally bold,
aggressive.
Because that's what I heard.
And then I put the
opposite in as well.
So there are, for
example, quiet people
in the book who are very
introverted and still heroes.
And then there are noisy
people in the book too,
who are very outgoing
and able to lead
through their social skills.
AMY YURY: So I have a
couple more questions,
but I want to give you
guys a chance to ask Joanna
some questions about
centered leadership,
about women's leadership, about
grow where you work, about life
challenges, about bringing
your daughter with you
along the journey.
And so on that I just
will ask one more
question then turn
it over to you guys.
What do you hope?
Obviously, you've
mentioned Gabby,
and she's part of
the intro of this,
in terms of the impetus
for writing this book.
Beyond your own
family, what do you
hope people will take
away from this book?
JOANNA BARSH: I am
passing the baton.
So I'm 64 years old.
I worked my-- not my whole life.
I worked in the movie
business and some other things
before McKinsey.
But you are the future.
Millennials are our future.
So my hope is that
this book accelerates
enough people to
take on challenges
and become leaders
at very early ages.
And maybe you already are all
leaders who are in this room.
And by leader, I
don't mean somebody
who runs a company with
a million employees.
Leader meaning somebody who
sees something and makes it
happen because you
believe it should happen.
It should be the way reality is.
A person with vision.
A person with a drive.
Some kind of purpose.
And if you don't have
any of that right now,
I hope this book will help you
on your journey to find it.
Because it took me 50 years
to realize that meaning
is, for me, the most
important thing in life.
And it sort of beats all else.
Clearly loving, having friends
you love, having family you
love helps you
along that journey.
But I discovered, at least
for me, that it wasn't enough.
That you needed to be
able to help people
be part of something bigger than
you, and that's what this is.
So I want you to take action
based on the challenges
that you're facing.
That's what I want.
AMY YURY: I'm going to
turn it over to you guys,
if you have a
couple of questions.
JOANNA BARSH: They're stupefied.
Like, oh my god.
AMY YURY: Kick us off.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, in
the dangerous question
to take us off
track a little bit.
But I'm dying to know, how would
you think about the challenges
that you've framed in
the book for Millennials
compared to Gen X, and does it
matter if you're in the Gen X
generation working at Google?
What do you-- how do you
do see that dividing line?
JOANNA BARSH: It's over for you.
[LAUGHS] I'm just kidding.
Just kidding.
AUDIENCE: That's what
I'm worried about.
Where's that chapter?
[LAUGHTER]
JOANNA BARSH: Yeah.
And there are a couple
of you in the room
who may consider yourselves
more Gen X than millennial.
Gen Xers told me that they
were raised to suck it up
until they reached the
goal that they wanted.
That for some reason, they felt
the loyalty of the company,
that if they were to wait it out
and gain the skills, that they
would get where
they wanted to go.
And millennials basically
said, I'm out of time.
I can't wait that long.
In fact, maybe I
can wait a year.
So to me, that was the
fundamental difference
between the two.
And as Sheryl
Sandberg admonished me
just a few weeks ago, never
say all, because it's not
true of all people.
It's always true of some
people, but not all people.
So Gen Xers, I think,
can learn a lot
from Millennials, which is
what are you waiting for?
Do it now.
Take the risk now.
Ask the question now.
And if somebody says
no, they say no.
You will have learned
from the experience.
And I said something
a few minutes ago
that a lot of the
people in the book
took on challenges and quote
unquote, "did not succeed"
in the normal scheme of things.
Right?
They didn't get the
promotion or the gold ring
or whatever you were
hoping they would get.
But they learned something.
So in that sense, they succeeded
through every challenge
that they met.
There was a story of a
woman who got a bad review.
Actually it was a
pretty good review.
She worked for a tech company.
Not yours.
And she was an African woman.
Set very high
standards for herself.
And so she didn't like
the review she got.
And people didn't
like her, apparently.
That was in the review as well.
That she's pushy, and
she set the bar high,
and she couldn't
stand mediocrity.
Does this sound familiar?
And everybody around her
was mediocre in her mind,
so she quit.
And I had the
conversation with her,
I'm sure that company
was sad that she quit.
But she said, this is not the
culture I want to be a part of.
I don't want to fit
in and have harmony.
I like reaching for perfection.
And so the only thing that
saddened me with her--
and I call her [? Efe ?] in the
book, if you read the book--
is that she was striving
for perfection because she
felt she had to make it.
It's one thing to
strive for perfection
because it motivates you.
It's another thing
to actually think
you have to achieve
perfection, because that
ain't going to happen.
So in that sense,
[? Efe ?] made me sad.
But I kept in touch with her.
She ended up in a start-up,
and she's really happy doing--
striving for perfection
and creating software
that the world needs.
AMY YURY: So you just said
the difference is act now
versus wait a little bit later.
And one of the--
the first chapter
hit me personally
because I just lost a
longtime colleague who said,
I just have--
I don't have passion in what
I'm doing here any longer.
And you mentioned in
the book though that you
say, as part of the
toolkit, maybe wait a year
before you actually make a move.
So how do you think about--
JOANNA BARSH: Yes, but there's
a lot you can do in that year.
AMY YURY: Yeah.
I mean, so do--
I mean, because you're saying,
Millennials want to act now,
and you are giving more
that advice that I would say
is take a little bit
of time before you just
make that action.
And that was the same
advice I gave her.
I said, just stick it out
for another couple months.
Try to do this with
your job differently.
Do this.
And she just-- she came back to
me after taking a little short
leave and just said, I can't.
I just-- I'm no longer--
my head and heart are
no longer in this.
So.
JOANNA BARSH: Well, first
of all, the good news
is you may have lost her, but
the world didn't lose her.
AMY YURY: No, I know.
And I'm helping her
find something else.
So--
JOANNA BARSH: So
let me rephrase.
She was probably pretty
busy while those few months
were going by in which she was
meditating on her decision.
So let's say you are at a
job you don't want to be in.
And I'm telling you, maybe
you should wait a year,
because it's a brand new job.
You will not have seen
the whole business cycle
if you leave in three months.
Because if it's a really
bad fit, you'll know it.
You should leave right away.
If, in fact, you're
just uncomfortable,
you're not learning fast
enough, you feel stagnant, then
what do you do?
Well, you talk to
a lot of people.
So you take that time to learn.
Go learn something else.
Do something outside of work
that expands your horizons.
So don't wait as in, OK.
I guess slow cycle
starts in five hours,
so I guess I'll just hang
out here and go there
tonight and see if I
can pick my spirits up.
Instead, you really
just network like crazy.
If you're introverted,
absolutely network like crazy.
And go ask people
what their jobs are.
Learn how to do--
ask your boss.
I want to do more.
I'm bored to tears,
for God's sakes, Amy.
Give me something else to do.
And Amy will dream it
up and give it to you.
And you won't get paid more,
but you will have learned more.
So during that year,
be busy growing.
And there are very concrete
things you can do to do that.
I see this gentleman's
patient as can be.
AUDIENCE: Well,
thank you for coming.
JOANNA BARSH: Debunking
Millennials yet again!
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHS] I
just had a quick question
for either one of you.
If you guys have a
story or anecdote
from early on in your
careers, the first time
that you maybe did have this
impactful leader, and maybe
what it looked like
to you, or how it did
influence your
career going forward.
JOANNA BARSH: Take it away, Amy.
AMY YURY: The question is did
I have an impactful leader?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Early on in your career, was
there anybody that stood out
and really, you
kind of recognized,
oh, this is an obvious great
leader, and we're really bad,
and they're helping
me in this way, pushed
you to maybe do something.
Maybe challenge you in some way.
AMY YURY: So yes on
both sides, right?
Those that were not as--
those that you don't admire,
and you observe very carefully
for all the things that
you make a long mental list
of the things that you'll
never do when you're a manager.
And then I love--
actually, Eileen
Naugton is somebody
that endorsed Joanna's book.
And Eileen started in
the New York office
a long time ago,
when I was here,
and she sat one
cube away from me
and became somebody that I
helped her figure out how
to navigate Google because
she come from Time Inc.
And so I helped her
figure out Google,
she helped me then learn
a lot about leadership,
women's leadership, and we
became longtime friends.
She's obviously gone on
to be many different roles
within Google, and
most recently is now
our head of People Operations.
And I had the opportunity
to see her last week.
And one of the
things, she had this--
did a talk on leadership
a long time ago.
And she said, be a snob
for talent, meaning
hire really amazing people.
People that are better from you.
That was one of the things.
And she also gave me
a lot of permission
early on to not always be
thinking about vertically
climbing, but the
importance of horizontal,
and as Sheryl refers to
it, climbing the jungle gym
to have lots of
different experiences.
And having somebody
like her, who
had done that in her
career, she's moved,
and now you see, even
within Google, to lots
of different roles
and functions, kind of
gave me permission to
think about doing the same.
JOANNA BARSH: Sometimes villains
can actually teach you as much
as great leaders.
So early in my career,
I worked in retail.
And there was a woman who
was my height, which means
that she was height challenged.
Mrs. Wilner.
And she tore people down.
She actually enjoyed it.
So I think she was on the
spectrum of sociopaths,
close to the edge.
And I developed a bloody nose.
It would come unpredictably.
I was running some
shops in a retailer.
And I did all kinds of
cool things in those shops
to get people to actually stop
and buy things or even just
look.
So I had everything
upended, and it
looked all like it would
fall apart in a second.
And she took the whole
team to the shop,
and in front of
all the customers,
screamed at me till
I was in tears.
So that was my earliest
memory of what it's really
like to work for a villain.
And so I switched
retailers, and I
ended up with a taller, blonder
version of the same woman,
and worked for her.
And she did similar
things that taught me,
essentially, if the person
doesn't want you to succeed,
there are a billion
things that you
have to get right in your job,
and you will get something
wrong, and they will find it.
So I learned that I
couldn't be perfect.
That it was really
embarrassing when
I had a bloody nose
in front of customers.
And it gave me the impetus
to go to business school
and completely change my career.
So I went from retail to
consulting, where people--
only clients yelled at me.
[LAUGHTER]
It got a lot better.
AMY YURY: Another
important message
that I give and have
tried to follow,
which is once you work
for a terrible boss,
you kind of say, OK.
JOANNA BARSH: Cut your losses.
AMY YURY: Yeah,
find great bosses.
AUDIENCE: So I opened up
your book on an airplane,
and I think it was
in the forward.
But I was reading
that what I really
love about it is it's designed
to-- you can read any chapter.
You don't have to go
chapter 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
And I think that's a
really unique approach.
I went straight to
the table of contents
and was looking at like, hm.
What do I want to
start with here first?
I wanted to ask you why
you made that choice
and if that was based on some
of your interviews with people
that you met with,
based on what books
are available in the marketplace
and how they're structured,
or what led you to
make that decision.
JOANNA BARSH: The simple answer
is I did structure it in a way
that I thought people,
on average, would evolve.
However, you're going to be
only interested in the challenge
that you're facing.
So you should start with that
challenge, and get into it,
and see if you can
get value from it.
I enjoyed all the chapters, and
I spent a lot of time thinking
about where they should go.
So it turns out that
there are a couple
of basic themes in the book.
One is about fear, and
that shows up in pressure.
It shows up in superheroes.
And it shows up in taking
risk or speaking up,
daring to challenge.
Another one is caring,
meaning, purpose,
that shows up in the first
and the last chapter.
And feeling purposeful.
And then there is a third
theme around people.
And so I put all
those guys together,
bringing people
on board even when
you just wish you could just
tell them what to do and make
them do it, and they
just won't do it.
Or working with creeps.
Or trying to get a sponsor.
So those kind of fit together.
But you're going to have the
best experience of the book
if you start with
what matters to you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AMY YURY: All right.
Time for two more questions.
I know we're running
a little over,
for folks that have to leave.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So I guess, after
listening to you,
I fall in the
Millennial category.
I thought I was a Gen X.
Something that I've noticed--
JOANNA BARSH: I'm
a Millennial too,
even though I'm an old one.
AUDIENCE: Something I've noticed
in trying to network or start
new conversations
is that often, it's
really hard to get on the
connecting side with people.
As often, I find that because of
whatever perceptions they have,
they want to other you instead.
And so I know that listening
to them is a good strategy
and should try and
bring them back,
but it's always like, how do
you get to that listening side?
How do you ask questions
that will help open them up?
Or what are strategies that
you can do getting to that part
or in that process to maybe open
them up, maybe bring them back.
JOANNA BARSH: That's a
really good question.
So there's a couple of things
for you to think about.
One is who do you admire.
And as you reach out
to people you admire,
actually tell them why you
admire them, specifically,
not generically.
There is a woman in the book
whose name is now escaping me.
Jet lag.
Let's blame it on
that or my age.
But anyway, she always
starts with specific praise
that is genuine.
And people love to
hear about themselves.
So if you start with that,
you've now opened them up.
And then ask a question of
what's important to you.
For example, Amy is an
extraordinary marketer,
and you tell her that,
and then you say,
I would really like to
learn more about the skills
that you developed early on.
Is there a way that I
could, without taking any
of your time, learn from you?
And she might say,
just walk with me here.
Or just come to this
meeting with me.
So there is that way
of saying, don't--
instead of saying,
will you be my mentor,
which the only answer is no.
Because I'm really--
everybody is really busy.
But to say, could I just walk
with you down in the elevator?
I have one question for you.
That's one way to do it.
And you've got to have
the questions that
matter to you, that you think
will matter to that person.
The other thing that
Sheryl taught me,
and we've interacted now since
2013 because of our shared
passion for women, is the effort
to help has to be specific.
So you might say as
a younger person,
I really want to help you.
And that's a burden.
So you think about,
by helping you,
what I'd like to do for you
is look at all the research
that we have access to, and then
I'm going to collate it for you
or do something.
So the specific help
that you offer, then
I could just say yes or no.
I probably would say, oh
my god, you're such a doll.
Would you please do that for me?
AMY YURY: That was how I ended
up becoming better friends with
Eileen in the early days, when
she was starting Women@ here
in New York.
And I said, well,
let me just come,
and I'll take notes and follow
through on the action items.
And she was like, great.
But it was being very
specific with how
I could help, with something
that was important to her,
but very tactical and specific.
So.
Last question.
Or we have two.
You guys want to
both fire them away?
AUDIENCE: Who's chivalrous?
AUDIENCE: So I wanted
to ask about the slide
where you had perceptions of new
leaders compared to old leaders
and what you think will prevent
the new leaders from ending up
like the old leaders.
Do you think that it's the
company's culture or something
with Millennials
that will end up
changing things for
the future, or will we
see how things are happening
from the old leader's
perspective and say
we've got to get in line.
JOANNA BARSH: So there's
this psychological research
that was done on monkeys.
And it was-- I'm
trying to remember.
I think Adam Grant wrote it
up in the book "Option B,"
but McKinsey uses
it a lot as well.
So there's this notion that
there are a bunch of monkeys.
They're in a pen.
And there's a beautiful bunch
of bananas up these stairs,
and the first monkey
goes up to get it,
and he gets doused with water.
Like, really a horrible hose.
He falls down.
So the second monkey
goes, I can do better.
I can do this.
Goes up.
Water.
Third monkey.
After a while, the
monkeys stop going up
the ladder to get the
bananas because they
know what's coming.
The monkeys die.
Sad, but it happens.
They take the monkey out.
They put a new monkey in.
The monkey doesn't
go up the ladder.
The new monkey.
And why is that happening?
Because the older monkeys are
saying, you go up the ladder,
you're going to get
shot with water.
It's a horrible experience.
Don't do it.
Now obviously, they do
that in monkey talk.
But they figure out.
They literally hold that young
monkey from doing that thing.
That's my fear.
My fear is that cultures tend
to show us how to be successful,
and the young people who
are the most successful
in the culture's definition will
mold to look like the leaders.
And this is one of the many,
many reasons why it's harder
for women than men,
because men are
more capable of mirroring the
man at the top that they see.
It's much harder for
women to do that.
The second thing that happens
to people is you get successful.
So you're a young
person, and you're
getting success in this
formula that you don't even
know you have.
But it becomes a
formula pretty quickly,
and then you just repeat it.
And as you are successful,
your mind starts to shut down.
Like, I'm successful doing this.
This is efficient.
I'm going to do it again.
I'm going to do it
again and again.
Make all this money and be
famous and all these things.
And you close yourself down.
And so one of the
things I noticed
when I interview older
very successful leaders
is they weren't that curious.
They had it.
They knew the story.
They delivered the story.
And they were done.
So those are the
two giant rocks that
are threatening to crush you
as you go through the ladder.
And I think what you could
do to avoid it is one,
as a community, shift the
culture, which can actually
be done pretty quickly.
The leaders have
to want to do it.
They have to role model it.
And the second is to ask
yourself all the time
what can I learn here.
If you just start with that.
I'm successful, what
can I learn here?
It will help.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AMY YURY: I learned a lot.
I always do from you, Joanna.
AUDIENCE: I'll ask you later.
JOANNA BARSH: OK.
I'll be here.
AMY YURY: Wonderful.
Thank you for joining us.
JOANNA BARSH: You're welcome.
AMY YURY: Stay
curious, and we will
do our best to grow
and continue to grow
while we work here at Google.
So everybody, thank you.